foreign
thank you so I'm going to begin by
taking you back 140 years to 1882.
and uh
Bismarck is the chancellor of Germany
and he's reunited it just 10 years
earlier
and Gladstone is on the is prime
minister in Britain in the states
the Civil War is still a recent memory
and a relatively insignificant uh
academic called Frederick Nietzsche
published a book called what was it was
first translated as the joyful wisdom we
now know it as the gay science
and um at the time things weren't that
great for for Nietzsche certainly wasn't
very joyful he'd uh he'd had to abandon
his uh post he no longer had an academic
post uh nobody was really reading his
books
um the uh the gay science actually sold
uh the miraculous number of 100 copies
in the next 10 years
and soon he will be publishing his own
own books because no one was reading
them but uh nevertheless
the philosophy that he outlined in this
book had Echoes throughout the
intellectual history of the 20th century
and one of the claims that he made in uh
in the book in actually what he called
the third third book but it's they're
really chapters in length
um with the claim God is dead
and uh of course at the time it didn't
really have any impact because nobody
was reading it but uh it was remarkably
prophetic because at the time in in
Europe 90 of people were baptized when
when Nietzsche was writing this and now
the figure is something around 10
percent
so uh the decline in religion was almost
continuous from uh Nietzsche's nietz's
remark and he went on to say God is dead
and we have killed him
and uh of course
what he's understood to have meant by
that is that human knowledge the
unfurling of the Enlightenment gradually
undermined the belief in a in a
knowledge which came from a higher
authority
and uh and uh so it has developed now
what I want to really talk about today
is well what has replaced God
and it seemed to me what we've replaced
god with is reality
and for those of you who've taken leave
of God
um reality probably feels pleasantly
down to earth it may not be very
um
magical in the way that some people see
God as being and and have the mystery of
the universe to it but it's got a
pleasantly down to earth practical
exercise and we can make progress in
terms of uncovering reality
there's something rather strange about
this idea of reality
because the more we explore it the more
it seems to have
characteristics which are rather similar
to those that previously applied to God
so well we'll start with the one which
I'm sure you can all go along with it's
uh it's everywhere and everything isn't
it reality but it's all it's all
unnerable and unattainable and evasive
and he might not be quite so convinced
of those things and I'm a I'm a uh
philosopher who has argued against
philosophical realism which is the idea
that we can describe reality so you
might expect me to say that reality is
uh unattailable and unknowable and so
forth
but in the last 10 years or so a whole
slew of uh neuroscientists have have
come to a similar view
so for example Donald Hoffman he's at
University of California Irving and he
says whatever reality is it's not what
you see
what you see is just an Adaptive fiction
and David Eagleman at Stanford
University says reality is an Illusion
perpetuated by our brains that leading
neuroscientists investigators in the in
perception and they're not alone there
are others and I'll set uh bo Lotto
um a whole load of neuroscientists now
are questioning uh whether reality is an
illusion and of course it's not just
neuroscience physics as well has
uncovered The elusive character of
reality you know we started on the idea
that reality was made of lots of small
bits which we understood to be atoms and
uh well we've opened the Chinese boxes
haven't we we have protons and neutrons
and we had quarks and leptons and bosons
and so forth and then you examine what
those particles are and
um the actual material stuff of them
gradually seems to disappear and we're
left with um fields and energy so from
some people even say uh we're just left
with the mathematics so we seem to have
lost the stuff of the universe uh as far
as physics is concerned and some of the
biggest physicists of the last century I
mean Werner Heisenberg he won the Nobel
Prize for creating uh quantum mechanics
and his interpretation is the one that
is widely used
and he came to the conclusion in the
Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics objective reality has
evaporated
and furthermore and he was a philosopher
too he wrote a rather excellent book
called physics and philosophy he he went
on to say we have learned that exact
science is possible without the basis of
metaphysical realism
and more recently
Stephen Hawking man who originally
initiated The Theory of Everything
abundance 2010
he concluded there is no mortal
independent test of reality it follows
that a well-constructed model creates a
reality of its own
so we've got no way of looking through
to see how reality is independently of
our of our models
so
you can see that the questioning of
reality is now coming from all sides and
what is a root underlying this
questioning
is the idea that we can't find a God's
eye view a position to look down at
where we are and see oh that's how it is
because we come from our perspective we
come from a perspective which is a
function of our physiology a function of
our our society and history a function
of our language and so we can't somehow
Escape that perspective to see down to
see how reality is in itself
now this puzzle about reality is
even more puzzling than it first appears
because one of the things about saying
that reality is an illusion is that it
looks as if
we we might be able to overcome the
illusion we might be able to you know
fill up a curtain and look behind and
see see what's really going on
and of course
the point is because of the perspective
or character of our of our thought we
can't do that because any anything that
we peer through to is going to be
perspectival as well people have had a
go you know a few hundred years ago
people have suggested that everything in
our in our heads Consciousness was
reality or were part of a universal
consciousness
more more recently there's been a
Temptation amongst some philosophers to
be attracted by the idea of pan psychism
the idea that out there
um material things are also a bit
conscious
but these these accounts of what's
what's ultimately out there suffer from
the same problem
they're words in our in our language
they're they're a function of our
framework they're we can't break through
to to an alternative story which is
going to somehow replace our accounts of
of reality with with with something else
and so they're implausible Solutions
uh we've just got to give up on the idea
that we're going to arrive at a solution
that the the puzzle there's a further
twist to the way in which it is it is
tricky
so
some
people faced with this situation have
come to the view where the right thing
to do is to say nothing about the
relationship between ourselves and the
world nothing at all and the most
obvious example of this because he was
very explicit about it was
um wittgenstein's later work
he'd given up on the idea of describing
the relationship between language and
the world he essentially for the sort of
outlines that I've I've given you here
and
sequence to that he he avoided making
any overall claims about the nature of
that relationship
hiding strategy as it were in relation
to reality is not satisfactory either
and the reason that it's not
satisfactory is because in order to
understand
uh wittgenstein's later work
you have in a way to give him a
metaphysical story
and maybe the metaphysical story that
you might give him we might people would
might give him different ones but
something along the lines of we are at
play in a language game
but if we can say we're playing a
language game then well we've cracked it
haven't we we know what's going on
and and so the way that we have to
understand the later Victory he said oh
we you just have to read my aphorisms
and you'll catch on but the problem is
the way we catch on is to impute to him
an overall view which he is avoiding
stating
so quite a tricky game this uh problem
with reality and our recognition that we
cannot describe the world and yet
what do we then do about it
now
back in the 18th century the great
philosopher Emmanuel Kant
started from the position that we have
knowledge and he thought we've got to
work out how thought Works in order for
us to
uh have knowledge in the end and he used
that build a structure of the necessary
structure of how we think in order to be
able to
um have knowledge
and it seems to me that the Contemporary
situation is in fact exactly the reverse
we have to start from the point of view
of recognizing that there is no
knowledge
that we are unable to see how the world
is and the challenge that we have is to
explain how it is that even though we
don't have knowledge of reality and even
though our theories don't describe
reality we are nevertheless able to
achieve all sorts of things we can talk
about what seems to be a shared reality
which seems pretty fixed that we can get
all things done we can uh make sense of
the world and so forth how can we do
that if we aren't able to actually
describe it and it seems to me that is
the central uh question that uh
philosophy needs to address and it's
certainly some something that I've spent
some time uh seeking to make some
progress with so how might we escape
this ozarkas initially it looks
impossible how can we do anything if our
if our accounts of the world have got
nothing to do and I do take the view it
has nothing to do with what's out there
how are they so how are they so
effective
so
as a as a help I think
we can just start off by thinking well
there are plenty of things that language
can't describe I mean aren't they I mean
it can't describe if you've never had it
the taste of an orange
doesn't matter how much you try and tell
people someone what the taste of orange
is your favorite you're never going to
succeed you can't describe to someone
who's never seen color what the color
blue is
okay
so why is that what why can't we
describe it
so I think one one sort of
indication of why is because you can't
divide it up so if you take the color
blue you can't somehow divide it into
bits and then describe the relationships
between the bits and there's nothing
that you can easily compare it with that
it's like it you you're you're somehow
stuck with just this thing and there's
no no way that language can reach
through to that thing
that it seems to me is what's going on
in our relationship to reality we can't
reach through
we can't we can't describe it so what
are we doing
how how can we think about what's going
on here and I think a starting point is
to think well
think of the world as a not thing it's
not anything in particular and it's not
differentiated
you might initially have a go at
thinking well it's a sort of
undifferentiated flux
but of course that would be to be a
description it would give you a sense of
oh I've got a sense of what it is but at
the moment just think of it well it's
not a thing and it's not divided into
things and it's language and thought
that close this potential into
individual things
and it's on the basis of those things
that we then intervene in the world
and how it's the detail of that how does
that work
well I'm going to give you a metaphor
think of uh our senses
as being like Flags in the wind imagine
for a moment you're in an underground
bunker and you've never experienced the
wind
and what you've got is a screen in front
of you see these flags waving
now you could uh build all sorts of
stories about these flags you could
identify patterns in the way the flags
are moving you could use them to predict
how the flags might work in future you
might notice that oh if it starts waving
over there it tends to move over here
you might build a ever more
sophisticated account of how those flags
are working which enable you to predict
really quite accurately how they're
going to predict in the function in the
future
but you're not going to understand what
the wind is are you
you're nowhere near the wind
it's got the wind's something else
altogether
but it doesn't stop your your account of
the flags enabling you to have an
account of what they might be how they
might be and how that how they could be
predicted to be in the future
and uh
that's I think exactly what we should
how we should think of our senses
functioning
so to use the uh parallel of the
scientific Story the scientific
Narrative of how our sensation is
working and I choose the scientific
story because I'm saying oh this is how
it is but it is the ones that we've got
we have to operate within the Frameworks
the narratives we've got within what I
would call the closures that we use to
make sense of the world and within the
context of that scientific story
each neuron and we have two billion of
them two billion
of sensory neurons each neuron responds
to the openness of the world
and unlike the flags and this is a
important and key factor unlike the
flags
it has only two responses
it either fires or it doesn't fire
that's all what's going on either fires
or it doesn't matter and indeed there's
a scientific law the all or none law
which is it doesn't make any difference
how you increase the input you only get
a firing out at the end there's no
halfway house it doesn't there's no it
fires a bit or it fares a lot it just
fires or it doesn't fire it's only two
two two spaces for it
and what the neuron is doing in that
situation is it taking the whole the
whole of the openness of the world and
it's turning it into one thing
the firing of a neuron
and we don't think the firing of the
neuron is a description of the world do
we we don't think somehow out there
there's a description of the firing of
an era no it's a response
our our experience is a response to the
world not a description of the world
and what we do is we take those
responses and we then build an account
of them
which enables us to intervene
so
having had all of these initial closures
as it were of of the way that the
neurons are generating something in
particular we then we then have another
layer
so we might take a million of these uh
neurons firing as a patch of blue
but that patch of blue just like the
firing of the neuron is not out there
it's how we hold all of those million
neurons as one thing not as a million
different things as one thing
and that gives us something blue and we
do that with all of our inputs so all of
our inputs we turn into uh the things as
it were which are the the sensations
that we experience and they're not
descriptions of the world they've got
nothing to do with the world they're
ways of holding it looking at our
response
no of course our sense is good held a
world differently couldn't they I mean
there are plenty of animals that don't
have the same physiology as we do who uh
have different inputs if you're dogs for
example have 40 times as many Sensory
neurons for smell that we do 40 times
that's double the number that we have
for site sites the most important for us
but they have double the number for
smell that we have a site so their world
their sensory world is utterly different
from ours
and they intervene on the basis of that
way of closing the world
and there's no right way is there
there's no right way of close it's not
as if the senses are somehow discovering
the right way to close it there's an
indefinite number of flags that we could
have to the world
and if you look across the animal
kingdom that's why you do all sorts of
different ways of of responding
now the closures of thought and language
are just the same thing
we often think of thought as being quite
different from Sensation actually uh in
some sense I don't think it is
that what's going on is that we thought
we are just holding doing the same thing
we're holding a lot of different things
as one thing
only with with thought we hold
Sensations as one thing so
I might pick this up and I I have a
sensation it's a bit bit cold it's sort
of hard
and um it's different where I hold on to
it so I get lots of different Sensations
and Visually there's an indefinite
number of visual Sensations for whether
I see it from this perspective or that
you know in fact there are you know
millions of them
and we hold all of those different
things
as one and the same
glass
but
that thing the Glass isn't out there any
more than the the sensory neuron firing
or the feel of the hardness uh or
whatever it's just a way of holding the
world
and of course
we could have hold them differently and
that's the key thing about thought is
that with physiology we've got no damn
choice
we've just inherited millions of years
of evolution it responding in the way it
is we look up at the sky on a sunny day
it is blue we can't hold it as orange
we've got no control over that and
that's a function of our evolutionary
process
it might have been different had we
evolved differently but we thought we
can change how we hold the world I mean
we could say okay
think of this as a container think of it
as a collection of of uh silicon atoms
think of it as a drink
think of it as a weapon
you can hop from one of those closures
to another can't you you can just hop
one after the other and we choose
through thought which one we'll go with
and there's no no right one there's no
underlying thing oh it really is a glass
rather than it really is a weapon that
ways of holding the world which enable
us to intervene
now
many people I think when first coming
across this thought
have a concern that this feels as if we
can make up any old thing
uh that Anything Goes
that's not right
we've got lots of constraint
I've explained the the constraint of our
physiology we've got no no room for
maneuver there and in terms of our
thought we inherit all sorts of stories
and closures about the world from our
our parents from our friends from our
culture from the the whole environment
that we're in and we can't abandon all
of that like overnight
we can abandon little bits of it we can
we can to some extent think of some
things a little bit different we can
choose as I say to see this as a weapon
rather than a glass but we can't abandon
it all at once we we have to stick
roughly to the sort of things that
everyone else is doing because otherwise
we can't communicate with them and
actually as children we're corrected all
the time we use the wrong word we say it
in the wrong way no no no no it's like
this
but it's not like that it has to be like
that it's just that that's the way we do
it in order to uh communicate
and there are many sort of
characteristics of this structure of
openness and closure which affect the
way we then think
we can see some radically different ways
here in the sense that computers close
the world in terms of naughts and ones I
mean they don't have experience I'm not
suggesting that but we've created
machines which divide the world into
naught and one it's immensely powerful
isn't it we the result of doing that
we've got machines that can think and
calculate much faster than we can that
can play chess better than we can that
can translate languages and all sorts of
things like that well sort of
but uh it's all from Norton one and in
the same way the same is the case with
our firing of the neurons we've got
everything from firing or not firing
that's all and it's just built in a
giant series of patterns and closures
that we've made to try and make sense of
uh where we are and how we can intervene
but
every closure that we have every idea
that we have that closes in the world a
certain way
does not succeed in describing the world
it holds the world as something
it doesn't describe the one it holds it
as something and
it's never going to succeed because the
world's always something entirely
different so there's an embrigible Gap
between our idea and how the world is
and that's true whatever framework we
come up with
so we shouldn't be surprised then that
no scientific theory is safe from
revision
well of course it isn't it can't ever
arrive they're always going to be issues
with our patterning however good we get
at it
and not just little things at the edge
they're always going to be fundamental
at some level
and that's why when we put forward a new
bit to our Theory we can always ask
other questions to it so you know we've
created you know Dark Matter term Dark
Energy recently to to patch up our our
overall account of the universe which
was not working very well in the process
we we invented 95 of it but no matter
um uh but that's not the end of it we
can ask then questions about that we're
never going to get to the bottom of
those questions you sort of knew that
didn't you you sort of knew we were
never going to get to the bottom because
if we did we could just pack up our
universities we could all go home and it
will be over
and wouldn't life be dull
so
we sort of know this but this is us an
explanation of you know why that's the
case
no theory is safe and all of our
theories are going to fail so what does
this mean what do we what should we do
well I think that we have to rethink
what it is to believe something
we can't first of all
it can't arrive it can't be an absolute
story of the world
but secondly it can't attempt to be an
absolute story of the world
and we have to think about that uh uh
claim in a different sort of way it's a
claim that it might enable us to achieve
something
now
you might feel well I don't really like
this I don't I've I've been you know
I've learned all about reality at school
I've grown up I've had a I've had a
lifetime of understanding I've got some
sense of where I am and now you're
telling me you know we've got to give
all of this away and I'm going to be
lost and uh and uh and it sounds very
scary
well it's not very scary
we've got these Frameworks which have
enabled us to do all sorts of things
which have enabled us to understand the
world in ways which are in some ways
immensely successful in some ways rather
less successful
but we don't have to give them all up we
in fact we can't give them all up we
couldn't we we we couldn't even begin to
imagine what it would be to do that so
we've just got this stuff of where we
are
and and that uh we can operate within
and we need to try and improve it and
make it better and more effective
but at the same time we can keep as it
were the the
um magic of being alive the idea that
there is something that we are never
going to get to the bottom of that we
can explore that we can have new
potential to do things that we can't do
at the moment we can hold the world
differently if it's gone wrong instead
of thinking well we're just trapped you
know this is this we just no no let's
just think about whether we can whether
we can hold it differently and make it
make the world a little bit better in
some in in some ways
now
the tools of the Enlightenment were
observation and reason
and um they were of course immensely
successful they've also run into trouble
haven't they a lot lots of things that
we've developed with the enlightenment
which have generated their own problems
but the tools in terms of enabling us to
improve the models will be very
successful and
they have misled us though as a result
of their success into thinking we are
uncovering that reality and we just have
to give up on that bit of it
now some people understandably in the
light of this have tended to think well
I'm a bit nervous about this observation
and reason I I don't like it seems to be
a monolithic story of the world I don't
want to buy that story well that's quite
right
because of course those tools were used
to pursue certain ends and uh the the
goals of a culture and the people who
are running that culture but we don't
need to give up the process of looking
to see where there are closures are
successful and whether they conflict
with other ways that we want to hold the
world so I think we need to double down
on observation and reason we just have
to give up thinking that we might arrive
at the truth
so I think you going to encourage you to
think of reality is a theological notion
it's a superstition
and that's why those characteristics in
the outset of everything and everywhere
and unattainable and unavailable and
Elusive feel rather familiar
it's a theological notion and it's time
to give up on our Superstition in favor
of an alternative perspective where we
see the potential we have to intervene
in the World and Achieve things and to
express ways of holding it that enable
us to do things we can't do at the
moment but not to imagine that we have
arrived or that we can ever arrive
now
I just want one brief PostScript to the
story that I I've given you
which is of course
this account of openness and closure
um
doesn't claim to be the truth either
because like all other theories it's a
way of closing the world
but that doesn't mean to say that I
don't think it has value it just means
this is a way of holding it I think it's
got a lot of things going for it
surprisingly enough
you know one of the one of the things
about it is that it enables us to I mean
we live in a very divided world don't we
and it seems to be coming ever more
divisive
and I think it's just possible that
giving up on the idea that any of us are
ever right might be might be a
preferable space it doesn't mean to say
we can't pursue things that we want to
pursue
but it does mean that we can think that
we aren't right and we don't are less
tempted to somehow impose them on
everybody else
doesn't stop there being disagreement
we've got different things we want to do
with our accounts of the world and our
closures but it does mean perhaps that
we have just a little bit more humility
about our own accounts
and and uh it seems to me that the the
account of openness of closure that I've
provided you with here enables us to
have all of the strengths of the
Enlightenment tradition in one sense
have that Science and Technology have
those things that have helped our our
lives like anesthetics and so forth that
have undeniably good things we can have
all of that and at the same time have
the
um wonder and the imagination of the
Arts we can have the down-to-earth
practical stuff and we can have the
mystery of what it is to be alive
and uh that seems to me a pretty
exciting uh place to be
just one final thought which is that
what I'm offering you here therefore is
in a way a way to hold the world
which has the appearance
of holding it fast
when the world cannot be held at all
thank you
[Applause]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV